for today's classic interview we're
going back to an interview that I
actually mentioned last week and there
could not possibly be better timing for
this given what's going on with net
neutrality back in August of 2014 I
interviewed someone named Crystal High
who was booked on the show under the
pretense of being a sort of you know a
great speaker about the importance of
net neutrality blah blah blah and I
uncovered during the research phase
before the interview that she had
actually been booked by a cable industry
lobbyist also a lobbyist for the
internet service provider industry and I
basically outed her during the interview
it gets sort of awkward at one point but
it is endlessly fascinating we will go
back to my interview with crystal high
about net neutrality from August of 2014
take a look at this I'm joined today by
crystal high who is the founder and
editor-in-chief of politics 365 and
we're here today to talk about net
neutrality Internet freedom crystal I I
have to admit I'm not particularly
optimistic right now about the future of
Internet freedom and when I step back I
see that we have a former cable
executive Tom wheeler working within the
FCC I see that we have astroturf groups
being funded by the cable lobbies posing
as citizens groups meant to sway public
opinion on the matter and when I step
back and think about five years down the
line I can't say I'm particularly
optimistic about having a true free and
open Internet do you agree with me on
that or do you disagree yeah I mean
honestly I think you should be
optimistic because one of the things
that we're finding now around the whole
net neutrality discussion is that
there's a lot of vocal participation by
people on all sides of the issue I'm
generally inclined to believe that you
know there are certain principles that
everybody would agree to right nobody
wants their content block nobody wants
to see their content degraded or slowed
down this whole notion of you know fast
lane slow lanes I think that by and
large people are saying oh no no that
that's not anything we're looking for
unless there are those cases where say
you know you have a
medicine Ave we're talking about public
safety applications and things that
enhance education so I think there is
broad consensus truly around the goals
that we're trying to protect in terms of
preserving an open Internet I think what
we're finding some disagreement and some
frustration now is really around how do
we get there for one but then you know
the argument is also kind of devolved in
my opinion to this nitpicky sort of you
know so who's in your pocket how are you
making money and I think that misses the
point of the actual issue here something
I am generally optimistic that we will
arrive at a solution that is beneficial
to keeping the internet as we like it to
keep it as an engine of a open
expression and a place for commerce and
entrepreneurship and ideas and
innovation but I think it's going to
take some stepping back a little bit
from the table and I kind of thrown some
rhetoric to the side and say hey what is
it that we're really trying to achieve
here and how to best get that done well
let's take it a piece at a time I mean I
completely agree with you that there
definitely are certain basics that the
general consensus seems to be a kind of
on board with and you're absolutely
right about that but let me push back a
little bit about the who's in your
pocket thing kind of being a distraction
and I'll tell you an interesting story
you may find the story interesting a few
months ago I was approached and I was
pitched a guest his name is Everett
Ehrlich he was the former I believe it
was Undersecretary of Commerce for Bill
Clinton and he was pitched to me by the
DCI group and I said this sounds like a
really great guest he was pitched as
like a progressive guy for Internet
freedom so on and so forth and I
interviewed him and during the interview
he said some things that started
striking me kind of like the corporate
talking points that I had been seeing on
right wing websites and I said that's
interesting let me let me take a step
back for a second and I looked into the
DCI group and as it turns out the DCI
group has indeed been retained by
broadband of America they've been
creating these fake citizens groups they
are a top Republican lobbyists they are
they have Verizon as one of their
biggest clients and I got duped right I
book someone without looking into who
was booking them for me and as it turns
out you were booked through the exact
same organization the DCI group so what
is your relationship to that
organization how does this all work yeah
I mean I think the best way to describe
it is that I'm someone who has you know
after I was in law school and even prior
to that not always had an interest in
media and communications has been a
platform that I think is bar none one of
the best that we have to not only
describe you know what it is we want
from our country what it is we want for
ourselves but it's a platform that
enables a lot right from ideas to
commerce anything like that the Internet
is the Internet is a platform right
you're saying the Internet is this
platform yeah because I mean if you
think about media period right it's kind
of the bastion of free expression and
ideas but the Internet overlays some
really interesting nuances and aspects
to everything right because it does make
sure that we have some broader
opportunities for people who might not
be able to get into the media through
traditional routes and so this has been
something a space that I've worked in
and have developed a passion for over
several years now and I think whenever
you have people particularly people of
color who are willing to kind of speak
out on issues that matter to them you
find different groups whether it's DCI
group or whatever you know I mean their
PR firms all across the country that are
working on both sides of the issues no I
understand that get honest laughing
thank you I totally understand that
heart crystal but you know I mean so
you're african-american I'm Hispanic you
know etc but I don't know that that's
really in other words when I step back
and I want to since you brought up that
you don't think who's in whose pocket is
that important of an issue I find it
very interesting that one of the issues
I mentioned which is that there are
these fake consumer groups and so-called
Pro citizens groups that are really
right-wing lobbyists sending people
around that's a real concern to me well
I mean I think that should be a concern
but you also have to be careful to
distinguish what is this so-called
fake group and what a legitimate
organization that have had a long
history of working towards issues of not
only Internet equality but you know
media justice generally and so I think
that you know some of the criticism
we've seen lately has been a bit
worrisome to me because it picks people
who have even before these consultant
firms are astroturf groups and even
coming to existence you have
organizations that for decades for
centuries have been working for you know
in some instances of straight media
justice and other instances it's a
broader civil rights agenda a broader
consumer agenda that when they happen to
speak out on issues of importance to
their can to their constituencies that
there's somehow you know a problem or
like oh why are these groups talking out
on these issues I mean actually that's
the part that's troubling to me it's
assuming that an organization is an
astroturf group or that an organization
doesn't have a legitimate interest in
the matter at hand just because of who
might have pitched them or how you heard
of a group or who supports an event
that's what I think is problematic to me
that may be the case but when we step
back there's no question right that DCI
has been retained by a cable lobbyist
and has Verizon as a client if you're
getting paid by a cable lobbyist and one
of the big companies that has a stake in
this wouldn't any reasonable person
question whether that is going to be an
organization that has the best interest
of consumers in mind or of their clients
right I mean there's a fiduciary
responsibility to the client you would
you would not deny that well I would
also like to think though that if people
are out front talking about issues if
they're willing to put their reputations
and their lives kind of on the line
because you know they are being front
and center I would like to think that
these are things that these people
actually believe and they're not just
being published you know I don't exactly
but unfortunately crystal the problem
with that argument is the same argument
we hear when we find out that
pharmaceuticals pay doctors to talk
about certain medications and when you
ask the doctor the doctor says you know
what I wouldn't talk about this
medication if I didn't think it was
worthwhile anyway and then the obvious
question
then why does somebody need to pay you
right it's the exact same issue with the
front groups around net neutrality which
is if these are the positions the
individuals hold anyway why does someone
feel the need to pay them we'll see I
don't think and you know correct me if
I'm wrong maybe you have information and
insight that I don't have but from what
I've seen a lot of the organizations
that are being called to the table
aren't being paid to talk about an issue
they might get an event sponsorship for
a program that's totally unrelated so if
you start talking about you know kind of
corporate social responsibility of the
operation investing in the organization
that kind of represent people who are
ultimately consumers of whatever said
corporation does that to me is something
that's fundamentally different than
saying hey I am paying you oh I totally
agree I agree with you which is kind of
why I was going to the question of at
the beginning of the interview to kind
of circle back which and I think this is
fascinating by the way what you said was
you don't think that the issue of who's
in whose pocket is that important and
you now said it may not necessarily be
that people are getting paid what is the
relationship here right because we know
that DCI is paid by broadband of America
the lobbyists are individuals like you
and Everett Ehrlich are you paid by DCI
I think you have to you know really
consider what it is you're suggesting
you're asking there you know like if
people are working on different issues
there could be a say consulting
arrangement that's separate and apart
from whatever it is people are
advocating for so I think you just have
to look at that issue so in other words
what you're saying is DC I may be paying
you as a consultant but they're not
paying you for the media appearances or
being a spokesperson so to speak for the
point of view that their clients espouse
right I mean you know everybody has some
sort of different kind of business
arrangement that they're looking to do
and did people have different ways that
they make their money that they are you
know however they are I happen to be a
lawyer I also happen to be
um you know editor-in-chief of an online
magazine I'm not exactly sure where all
F does I think he's a researcher or
something but you know everybody has a
different relationship so I think you'd
have to go through line by line and
figure out okay so what are you doing
what are you doing but if the fact of
the matter remains that people are
saying things that they legitimately
believe their views that they hold and
have held even prior to or before any
sort of relationship with whatever
consulting firm whatever group it is
you're trying to call to test I think
that that person's individual views is
that's what should be considered as kind
of fun and for most the most important
issues I don't disagree with you but I
do go back to this question of if that
were the case then why why are people
getting paid at all right in the doctor
medication example I think is the one
that stands in any case we've been
speaking with crystal high founder and
editor-in-chief of politic 365 really
helping us to shed some light on what is
and is not as she indicated going on
behind the scenes when it comes to the
net neutrality discussion crystal really
a pleasure having you on thanks so much
for have to do that